the war of the ancient dragons began
thousands of years ago and the odd tree
Capital came under siege led by a
gargantuan Dragon named Grand sax
the dragons wielded Heavenly bolts of
red lightning and so the Knights of the
earth tree learned to fortify themselves
against it and stayed on the defensive
until Godwin the golden delivered the
decisive blow he stood before another
legendary dragon known as dread Fortis
ax and defeated him
but instead of granting death
he showed Mercy he offered friendship
and it was with this act that the
ancient dragons and the golden order
truly became one
years later a dire plot was put into
action a plan to kill Godwin the golden
so a fragment of the Rune of death was
stolen from the Black Blade that was
designed to contain it this fragment was
then inscribed onto a set of black
knives which the black knife assassins
would wield and with cloaks of silver
that fooled the eye they snuck into the
capital and delivered the first Destin
death in a millennia
Godwin should have died a clean true
death
but he did not
instead as The Mark of Death was being
carved into his flesh it was at that
very moment also being carved into
another of his kin the lunar princess
Rani Rani got her wish and perished in
flesh alone
she freed her soul
but Godwin died in spirit alone and so
his body suffered an unimaginable fate
his living corpse would spread A
peculiar brand of undeath through the
lands between via death root and
wherever there is death root the hunters
of the Dead are sure to follow
there's no mistake is the death has left
its Mark once again
I'm sorry I cannot give you your proper
rights but at least you did not join
those who live in death your soul will
return to the Earth tree
in time
ah a tarnished are you I'm known as d
I hunt down those who live in death and
weed their death route heed my warning
The Village here has been touched by
death and worse yet it is home to a
mariner
if you value your life then go no
further
the dead have long been left to wander
and
what they need is true leadership
the Mariners can call to those who live
in death and offer them some semblance
of guidance but they make poor leaders
and even poorer Fighters
so it is that the dead continue to live
without a purpose well well
another fool who won't listen to reason
hey
but with a prowess for weed in death
root
I spotted the mark of this centipede
here in the village an ill Omen symbol
that should not be
someone or something threatens the
sanctity of the golden order and must be
eradicated
hmm
D claims to have seen the mark of the
centipede in this Village and it seems
he's talking about the death route here
which is at the very heart of those who
live in death this death route carries
the curse of the centipedal half-wheel
wound which raises the dead from their
graves ordering their bodies to life
without a soul without guidance and and
without Grace
how would you like to earn the strength
of beasts if you're inclined to haunt
more of those who live in death and weed
their death root then I'll introduce you
to garank
I have a matter of my own to attend to
and the Beast himself wishes for someone
to take my place
or say you
very well show me your map of Mark the
location for you it will lead you to
garank the Beast clergyman
the best deal sanctum lies past from
Great Bridge deep within the caled Wilds
past the vulgar militiamen who are short
brutal mercenaries and the Black Blade
Kindred who are a patchwork of Champions
put back together with corpse wax
they're all here in defense of garank
or should I say malikath he is America's
loyal shadow that once kept the Rune of
death bound within his Black Blade that
is until a piece of that death was
stolen afterwards he buried the Black
Blade deep within his very self so that
no one could steal it ever again
[Music]
death
feeding me
suffused with the Rune of death malekith
now hungers for death root desperate to
gather back what he strongly feels are
the missing parts of himself
tarnished
bring more deaths
I shall Grant thee I
feed me
more
but there was a time before the Rune of
death was bound and so there were other
cultures of death ways that were even
practiced outside the lands between
where the tarnished lived in Exile
greetings great Champion called by Grace
I am fear circumstances have compelled
my stay at the round table hope great
champion
would you allow me to hold you
but briefly
ah my thanks
you are
I was known
as a deathbed companion where I come
from after I received the warmth and
Lively vigor
[Music]
I lay
with the remain
remain Noble
to Grant him another chance at life to
do so
is the purpose of my being but before I
could bear the noble into new life I was
awakened
by the guidance of Grace
and chaste from my birthplace
[Music]
originally the deathbed companions
existed to provide a simple Comfort to
those who were dying but at some point
it seems it was discovered that a
deathbed companion could use the
Vitality of others to birth dead remains
into New Life
and so the deathbed companions became a
tool a path to rebirth for the
privileged who told the deathbed
companions who to lie with and when so
that one exalted being
might get a second chance at life
despite all that
I still wish to be a deathbed companion
so please
let me hold you like this
as often as it takes
[Music]
but it's not all about you after all you
are not the only tarnished that fear
lays with and who knows what secrets are
shared in her bed chamber
ah nice to meet you the pleasure's mine
Roger is the name I'm looking for a
little something here in the castle when
I'm not hot footing it from the troops
that is
but enough about me
what are you doing here in stormvale
Castle this place is bristling with
tarnished Hunters you know
they sacrifice Our Kind for grafting not
exactly a place I'd stroll into without
a purpose in mind
[Music]
many external threats have laid waste to
stormvale over the years and now the
castle is marred by mottled Thorns that
have worked their way through the
tortured Stone the soldiers mutter that
it's the curse of grafting that causes
such an Affliction but some talk of its
root being something much more Sinister
hidden deep below the castle that is why
Roger is here on a mission of his own
and as you square up against godric he
is searching for the source of the
mottled thorns and he finds it for the
world has grown crooked and if one
intends to put it to rights then they'd
best understand what happened to make it
that way
no matter the cost
the world is slowly being taken over by
the death route that is Godwin for when
Godwin died his body was buried in the
deep root depths in what seems like an
esteemed position directly below the
Earth tree this would have been done in
accordance with the practice of herd
tree burial a process which replaced
destined death for under America's
golden order death exists but it is not
the end and the roots of the earth tree
should call to all of the Dead In Time
reabsorbing them into the great tree
where they may one day be reborn
Godwin being a Great Hero likely
received the burial rites that placed
him as close to the Earth tree as
possible but this backfired horrifically
for the roots would instead take up
Godwin's cursed Essence like a tree
absorbs water and spread the mark of the
centipede throughout the lands between
via death route
so it is that those who live in death
were born
the hunters of the Dead would follow
I serve the golden order that I might
put this crooked land to rise
following only the guidance of the great
Elden ring
those who live in death fall outside the
principles of the golden order
[Music]
resistance sullies the guidance of gold
tainting its truth
and so it is the Vermin must be
exterminated
down to the very last
the hunters of the Dead are Fanatics who
are glad to have an absolute evil to
contend with but to such an evil even
exist in the fundamentals of order
are you acquainted with a man named
Roger you know the pitiest fellow hiding
away on the balcony he was a formidable
spellblade in past don't let his easy
Heir deceive you he was wise Beyond his
years Stout of heart and clear of mind
[Music]
ah so you've met d d is an old friend we
found ourselves journeying together for
a Time Bound by our exploration of death
but our paths have since diverged never
again to cross though that's hardly an
uncommon fate for two friends
[Music]
no more though you see him now
ravaged by Thorns muttering and rambling
like he's half dead already
couldn't change a thing I can't stomach
to watch take well the lesson friend
that's how you end up when seduced by
those who live in death when Grace is
solid it rots people from the inside
breaks them
this is what the golden order has been
reduced to godric the runt of the litter
dependent on the strength of tarnished
Champions but fear's favor is bestowed
upon her consults it allows them to
ignore any aches or pains for in death
there is only peace
for death there can be no sensation
ah you defeated godric and claimed
yourself a great Rune hmm looks like we
both got what we wanted out of stormvale
didn't we
well done friend always good to see you
safe
so
the misshapen corpse under stormvale
that is a sacred relic of the black
knives plot as that famed night of
assassination is known it happened
during the golden age of the Earth tree
long before the shattering of the Eldon
ring someone stole a fragment of the
Rune of Death From malacath the Black
Blade and on a bitter night murdered
Godwin the golden
[Music]
that was the first recorded death of a
demigod in all history and it became the
Catalyst soon the Elden ring was smashed
and thus sprang forth the war known as
the shattering I once wished to become a
scholar you see I've spent many an hour
scouring the archives for knowledge of
that fateful plot
and that thing is to blame for the shape
I'm in now I urge the utmost caution
don't disturb the corpse more than
necessary
[Music]
my dear have you ever heard of black
knife Prince
dear Roger likes to talk of them when a
bed
and the ancient plot in which the first
of the demigods was slain
the black knives wielded by the
Assassins who committed the ACT
along with the Impressions they made
somehow hide the truth of the conspiracy
is these Grand Affairs are hardly my
forte but dear Rocher began to weep as
he spoke
[Music]
in truth I've heard tell from someone
else about the black knife Prince that
Fascinate dear Roger so but it wouldn't
be right to give
if this duck as he is in the round table
Hall perhaps
you could make use of it
with a crudely drawn map in hand we can
find a living black knife one of many
who look purposeless in the dark places
of the lands between and D is here to
help you
[Music]
hello
you've been busy weeding death route I
take it
I thank you as your brother in arms
the black knives were after all
instrumental in undoing Dee's beloved
order so here he takes his revenge
and you walk away with an imprint of a
black knife
this is a black knife print I can
scarcely believe you managed to get your
hands on this
I beg of you lend me the knife print for
a time I'd love nothing more than to
tease out its secrets
half my body has been suffused with
death
I'm certain it will help me see
though only a fragment a very specific
ritual had to be performed to impart the
power of the Rune of death
traces of the one who performed the ride
are sure to remain in the imprint
truly you have my thanks
time can move rather slowly stuck here
you know a little conversation goes a
long way
[Music]
so Roger continues his investigation and
you continue to seek out death route
waiting for the truth of things to be
revealed you are basically put to good
use by everyone around you
I am pleased to see you again would you
like me to hold you
now
come closer
you are so
very warm
I heard that you lend a hand to Dear
Roger he seemed positively elated he
must be possessed of great mental
fortitude it anchors his will and
sustains him despite his Grievous wounds
you truly are a champion
to Dear Russia and myself too
my dear might I ask something of you
could you please find the owner of this
dagger I and return it to them
a certain person gave it to me
as a gift it's a very precious thing
it must have a special place in the
owner's heart
so I would like for the original owner
to have it back
if you wouldn't mind
this weathered dagger was once a special
weapon of gold and silver intertwined
except now it has been worn down and
marred by a black gash it's natural to
think that this weapon belongs to D but
then why didn't fear give it back to him
herself
well what have we here how did you get
your hands on that dagger
well
that hardly matters I know very well
whose dagger it is why don't I return it
to them for you good work bringing this
to me
it's almost as if they're playing a game
with the dagger arguing over whose heart
it truly deserves to be buried Within
and it's a game that D ends up losing
the fear developed a sorcery to oppose
the Roundtable hold a mist of death
blight that is only effective against
the tarnished especially if they
confront you in a small enclosed room
[Music]
finally it is returned to its rightful
place the stolen aloe brand
of the exalted Noble
I must bid you goodbye as well though I
ask you deliver this message to the
round table hold I am fear
deathbed companion heart Round Table
disturb not the death of Godwin the
exalted we who humbly live in death live
in waiting to one day welcome our Lord
what right does anyone have to object
our Lord will rise
the lord of the many
and the meek
all this time fear was getting closer to
recovering the hello brand the D stole
from Godwin for this hello brand is the
key it's the curse mark that the black
knives carved to split death in half
which started all of this in the first
place
fear has a use for it while D is dead
but D is also alive for Devin and Darion
are the Inseparable twins they are of
two bodies and two minds but one single
soul
this made them reviled by many but they
found solace within the golden order
which accepted their duality of the self
they even had armaments forged to
represent their state of being an
Inseparable sword and a twinned suit of
armor and these items long to find their
way back to the other day who yet lives
Devon Slumbers in the Eternal City
tormented by death blight
and it's here but he is said to have
stood before the prince of death
suggesting he was the one who carved the
curse mark from Godwin's flesh perhaps
he even used a weathered dagger to carve
it out perhaps this dagger was then
mockingly gifted to a rotten witch
setting into motion the events that
would lead to his brother darian's death
[Music]
the Mariners are a joke making your hunt
for the spreading death route an easy
one
it shows up in Lim grave in Leonia even
in the mountaintops of the Giants and it
is most common wherever there is
stagnant water which is a medium that
represents corruption and defilement and
the death root infects all manner of
creatures who meet their end sporting
these distorted pustules of Godwin's own
Visage deathroad even starts to get the
better of America's own shadow after all
in the end what we're feeding him is now
much more than just the missing
fragments of the wound of death
something has changed
strange
there's something else
I must consume more
put it away
I won't forget
again
I never appetite
my sin
I must have more
I must consume more
[Music]
it is
it is all consumed
still I am not stated
not nearly seated
America
is this
what cities
to sing
nice things
never be the same again
tarnished
by thanks
for thy long labor
but I have done
all I can
in this land henceforth
minor appetite
shall be my soul companion
farewell
[Music]
ah hello
was hoping to see you my examination is
complete
here's the knife print back with my
thanks
now I have a fairly good idea who
performed the ride upon the blade
the person who orchestrated the night of
the black knives
Luna princess Ronnie one of the children
born to King console Radigan and his
first wife ranala demigod and sister to
General radar and pray to reichardt
hers was the name I discovered in the
imprint if Rani truly is the one who
plotted that fateful night then she
should bear the curse mark of destined
to death somewhere upon her flesh
I would like you to procure it for me
and then all will be laid bare I will
have the answers I have sought for so
long do you know of those who live in
death
these Souls have committed no offense
they have every right to life only they
happen to touch upon a floor in the
order
by d's account these defiled themes must
be expunged
but truth be told I seek the curse mark
to save them
[Music]
if we're looking for someone to blame in
all of this mess then where do we land
does the guilt lie with those who live
in death who touched death root or with
Godwin who spawned it
or should we blame Ronnie who thought up
the plot in the first place
personally I think any fault goes even
further back to America who in her
hubris thought that she could free the
world from death
death and life should never have been
separated a fact that is more clear now
than ever
maybe I should tell you
lately I feel I'm on the precipice of
falling into a deep
fathomless Slumber and I have an inkling
it could spell trouble for you somehow
so I just wanted to get the apology out
of the way beforehand since you're so
scary and all
this is unfortunate
um
[Music]
good win
so
circus
forms
mm-hmm
[Music]
so whoever can obtain two halves of the
curse mark can a rune with his dying
breath Roger hints that fear might be
able to use this and a letter scrawled
by Roger on his deathbed tells us one
last thing it's that D had a twin
brother
and that the other D might be found in
an aqueduct beside the Eternal City of
nocron Roger implores us to put his
friend to rest and reunite the twins
which we do by returning Dee's armor
Roger goes on to reveal that Devin stood
before Godwin not far beyond this spot
and indeed Devon and the dagger were
deaf-blighted so we travel a little
farther upwards to a nameless City
that's overtaken by roots
and Godwin himself
oh Lord God win
oh my poor Sweet Lord Ling should have
died a true death
how could such a thing come to be
[Music]
it finally lies with God
with God defending his being with the
sap strength of every hero who lay with
her
including of course the famed spellblade
regime
[Music]
foreign
there you are I knew you would come what
is it do you intend to deny us and our
ways like the dogmatic brutes of the
golden order
you are an odd one
I am the guardian of those who live in
death they call me a foul and rotten
witch yet you still wish to be held by
me
[Music]
this is the other hello brand how did
you oh my utmost thanks with this
Godwin can take his rightful place as
first of the dead and claim a second
illustrious life
you are my
our true champion and though I can't be
of any use to you can I hold you tight
if only for a moment
foreign
and it will surely stir Within Me the
new life of the golden Prince
the first Dead of the demigods as the
Rune of those who live in death
please
do one thing for me brandish this child
my rune
and take for yourself the throne stay
the persecution of those who live in
death by becoming our Elden Lord
this is goodbye my dear but I am
satisfied I choose to lie with Godwin of
my own will
not the remains of one chosen for me and
I will bear a child who will inherit
your warmth too what greater blessing
could there be
deathbed combined
now Fear Can fulfill her purpose and
initiate a rebirth a gestated rune that
tells the broken story of those who live
in death
so for your lies with Godwin and she
dreams but it's within this dream that
we realize that there is something
lurking inside the prince of death a
being who even after all this time never
once stopped fighting against the death
in their companion they are the last
thing that stands between Godwin and his
new life and here they refuse to let go
for Godwin was a friend
they were the Great ancient dragon dread
fortesax
[Music]
foreign
ly you can bring the entire broken curse
mark itself into order The Mending Rune
of the death Prince which enables his
bastardization of life to become an
official part of death's story
But first you have to burn down the urge
tree
and walk alongside Flame to meet the
road of destined death
which leads to faram Azula a broken City
floating outside of time
[Music]
and against all logic deathroot now
grows here too
turns out nowhere is safe from its touch
even in faram Azula
where the true Rune of death is still
protected
by none other than malacath who
masqueraded as Greg so that you might
feed him death root and help him to
achieve the one and only task that
America saw fit to entrust him with
[Music]
this no matter
I hereby foul
the destined Death
Shall Not Be stolen again
foreign
[Music]
thank you
good boy looks though
call me
why
laughs
Prince of death take a good long look
see the Wrath of the golden order the
order's Justice writ in blood this is
what's become of Your Precious Witch
look at this rotten Hall no more
children can be got from this useless
flesh this is a proper death o Prince
behold your mother is dead
[Music]
this is Revenge you witch and you you
cool
this is the wrath of day
ah
hello
the rotten Witch Is Dead
the golden order on solid
now I can look my brother Darian in the
eye
honey Rays of gold
deliver my spirit
Darian honeyed rays
foreign
[Music]
ER of the golden order and murderer of
my brother
[Music]
I'll grind your corpse
[Laughter]
forgive me sorry
[Music]
as a deathbed companion fear had no
choice but to lie with others until the
guidance of Grace led her back to the
lands between where she used her
Chambers in the round table hold to
great effect biding her time listening
to the secrets told to her in private
until she could use the strength of
Champions to speak for others for the
downtrodden who had no champion
but soon they will
[Music]
please
do one thing for me brandish this child
my
and take for your for yourself
the thrust day the persecution of those
who live in death by becoming
our Elder
Elden
fear has finally laned with the remains
of one that she chose so that she might
gestate A New Beginning called The
Mending Rune of those who live in death
a gift to the undead who were born at
the very end of an age
duskborne before the sun rises once more
in a land where they no longer have to
hide
[Music]
the fallen leaves
tell a story
of how a tarnished became Elden Lord
in our home
across the fog
the lands between
our seed well look back upon us and
recall
[Music]
the age
of the duskborne
[Music]
alright hope you all enjoyed the video
we've now covered three of Eldon Rings
endings through prepare to cry four if
you include the first video about
Alexander being kind of related to the
age of fracture ending which is how I
think about it in my head and I'm
thinking the next episode will be the
last one based around an ending
I'm sure you can guess who's up next
it's time to talk about Rani Roger did a
lot of work in this episode sort of
setting up her story that's kind of his
legacy in game in a way to set it up and
we have a ton to work with for that
episode I'm really excited special
thanks as always to my partner on this
project Miss Pap one who was in charge
of all the visuals in this episode and
just look at these shots they're
absolutely insane it's like watching an
in-game cutscene half the time
special thanks also to quailarg and Smo
town for debating D and fear's questline
with me over Discord because honestly
there are quite a few ways that you can
interpret the weather dagger part of
that questline and I hope I did a decent
job presenting that part of the video
because it's always really hard telling
a story when there are multiple valid
interpretations of an event that could
all be the right one you know because
prepare to cry is a series that sort of
relies on me telling the story fairly
confidently
because I don't always want to be saying
you know maybe fear got the dagger from
this person or maybe she gave it to
Darion for this reason or maybe this or
maybe that there are other videos where
I'm happy to do that but prepare to cry
I prefer to have one interpretation and
this is mine but I do want a flag that
this interpretation might differ from
your own and that is totally fine anyway
I also want to give a shout out to the
artist for the intro who is John Devlin
and also the animator for that section
who is Xavier and together they created
some truly awesome scenes with the
dragons and Godwin and Rani and it's so
great to have their help in creating
these scenes that we never got to see so
thank you to them for that and then
thank you to my patrons who make
commissioning amazing work like this
possible I hope you're all enjoying the
Early Access the wallpapers and the
exclusive merch thank you and of course
thank you for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]